girl now you spending six dollars on a
starbucks grilled cheese
i literally had to look up on the app
how much this was because out of
principle i refuse to pay for a grilled
cheese because it's so quick and easy to
make at home so for the starbucks
version i looked it up they used
sourdough bread mozzarella and white
cheddar but i like colby jack so you can
use whatever cheese you like and
definitely be generous with this
and then as i'm piling it on i sort of
just shove everything a little bit more
towards the center so it doesn't spill
out when i'm cooking it
and then for the starbucks grilled
cheese the secret is they use parmesan
butter
to fry the outside part of the grilled
cheese so all you have to do is make
some butter some parmesan and then pop
your grilled cheese on there
and i like to just spin it around like
this so it's covered evenly and then i
pop a lid on top so it cooks all the way
through in the middle
then i put the rest of the parmesan
butter on top for the other side spread
it out nice and evenly like this and it
will be so freaking crispy and golden
brown you guys trust me you're never
gonna pay that six dollars again
okay you have to stop spending that five
dollars on your starbucks vanilla sweet
cream cold brew
i know it tastes really good but you can
actually make it at home and it's super
quick and easy all you need is some
whipped cream
half and half and some french vanilla
syrup and i also like to use this little
milk broth right here but that's
optional
so you're just going to grab your
whipped cream add a little milk in then
some of that french vanilla and then
you're going to mix everything up
together with your
little frother and if you don't have one
you can use a spoon to just mix
everything up together but using a milk
frother aerates the milk a little bit
gives it a very light and fluffy kind of
foamy texture and instead of cold brew
i'm actually making an americano today
so just some espresso some filtered
water
and then i just pour the sweet cream on
top and that's basically it you guys
this turned out so thick and creamy and
like really luxurious
even though i mix everything up together
it floated on the top because it is so
dense and amazing
okay scrooge mcduck not everybody has
six dollars for a grilled cheese okay so
let me show you guys
my version of the starbucks grilled
cheese but it's way better and it's
actually nothing like the starbucks
grilled cheese
this is my version but i'm just saying
you know like if you're craving that try
this instead
basically what you're gonna do is grab
some butter a bit of mayo and then
you're gonna pop your seasonings in i
use pepper a little pinch of salt some
garlic powder and some cayenne
and then you're gonna add in whatever
fresh herbs you like i put in some
rosemary some thyme and some basil i
also recommend dill but i didn't have
any
then i'm grabbing my sourdough bread and
fresh mozzarella and you guys i
recommend squeezing out the excess water
from this so your inside of the sandwich
doesn't get soggy then
cover both sides with this spread that
we made
grill it cover it with a lid okay so it
melts inside and you will get the best
cheese pull you've ever seen in your
okay so i used to work at starbucks as a
barista but that does not mean i condone
their chai concentrate okay
let me show you guys how to make a chai
concentrate at home that's more
authentic
more delicious and way cheaper than the
starbucks version so basically what
you're gonna do is grab
three cardamom pods some peppercorns a
little bit of cinnamon bark and some
cloves and then you're gonna crush this
up with a mortar and pestle or you can
also use a spice grinder if you have one
and then into a pan you're gonna add in
one cup of water and then toss in the
spice mixture that we just crushed up
right now
and then i also used a little piece of
ginger about that size ended up being
about half a tablespoon when it was
crushed up and then i tossed that in
there as well and i let everything boil
for about like three to five minutes
and then after that i'm gonna add in my
brown sugar i prefer brown sugar for
this recipe because it adds more of a
caramel flavor but you can use any sugar
that you like and then just
toss in your tea powder let it boil for
about a minute strain everything out
toss your ice in add your milk in there
pour your espresso shot and then
mix it in with your chai and that's
basically it you guys what other
starbucks drinks do you want to see from
me next let me know
you